Fox News is reporting that we're just
hours away from president Trump
declassifying and releasing that
controversial FISA memo the FBI and
Democrats are furiously trying to
prevent the memos release and we should
see what they are so desperate to keep
hidden as early as tomorrow it will be
released joining us now with reaction is
Democratic Congressman John Garamendi
congressman first off I got to tell you
this we want to congratulate you you're
a very brave person because you are just
the third Democratic lawmaker to come on
this show since it began three months
ago so my friend you are now a member no
really this club let's make it a weekly
a weekly thing we'll do it once a week
at least it's great to see you
congressman so tell us about this memo
and first my first question is why
haven't you gone to read the memo yeah I
was about to do so Tuesday morning late
Monday night the committee voted to
release it and I said I just assumed not
read the classified version of it
because if I do I can't talk about it
I'm on the Armed Services Committee Pat
been for the last eight years and I do
classified information virtually every
week often every day and I know that I
can't talk about it so I knew it was
going to become public and then I could
talk about it yeah all these congressmen
have been all over television they're
not talking about what's in the memo
they're talking about the need to have
transparency so are you saying all those
congressmen are violating their
congressional ethical obligations seems
like to look to the viewers I imagine no
I don't think so at all I know this is
coming out it's going to be out tomorrow
probably and we review it what's really
really important here is that we need to
recognize that we are in a highly
partisan very very charged environment
Democrats and Republicans both of them
going back to their corner coming out
fighting it out but what has to be done
here is to fully understand this then
the Democrats have their momentum the
Republicans have their memo put them
both out there let the public judge
exactly what this is all about we need
to know
we have a very serious challenge the the
CIA director mr. Pompeo said that he
fully anticipate that Russia will
interfere in the 2018 elections which
are coming up next month in March so we
need to be prepared however very little
almost nothing has been done about
protecting our election process that
needs to be done I understand that
completely but what is that we all do
well have some ammo
well the memo itself speaks to another
part of the problem that confronts us
and that is how do we you know that as
well as I do even though we neither of
us have read it but I bet you my bottom
dollar that has another deal of
collusion but it does have have to do
with is how a FISA application was
drafted and on what it was based and if
it's based on demo social research
congressman that should never have been
done that's the problem like you guys
are you guys are the oversight of the
executive branch you're the you do the
oversight of the FBI and the DOJ and the
American people weren't very concerned
about this investigation and I think the
people have a right to know allow me to
go back to the point I made a moment ago
and that is that we are in a very
charged highly partisan situation in
that committee in the Congress and
really around this country what we have
to do is to make sure that our
intelligence agencies are acting
properly under the restrictions and the
Constitution and able to protect this
nation all right but we know after
they've written in a report to try to
impeach the president I mean don't you
think we should know now if the basis of
today's Legation was faulty and there
are two reports Laura there is a
Republican report there's a democratic
you're apart I'm fine let's get it done
put them on the table and let's get the
information out that that's what we have
to do from that information to
be available to us come on just go
compete in the memo tonight and tomorrow
morning tomorrow morning it'll be right
at the top of the news cycle but here's
the point two things we need to do Laura
quick like we need to make we need to
make sure that our intelligence agencies
are able to protect us secondly exactly
both of those on the table and a hearing
well let's get it get the memos out
there and it's hot does this department
come before us we really appreciate it
let's go good know Moreau today's number
three okay you got number three back
there to tell your colleagues we don't
buy it it's okay to come on it'll be fun
all right